Transcriber: Ilayda Gokgoz
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Kendimi nasıl olduysa 12 yaşımda
dünyanın en yüksek ve Amerika’nın
en hızlı roller coaster’ı olan
Kingda Ka’nın sırasında
beklerken bulmuştum.
İlk Amerika ziyaretimdi ve ilk yabancı
arkadaşım Lauren son gün aktivitesi olarak
bizi Six Flags Lunaparkı’na götürmüştü.
Sıra demişken öbür bütün roller
coasterların önü en az 1-2 saat sıraydı.
Kingda Ka o kadar az bilinen,
o kadar korkulan bir şeydi ki
resmen önünde sıra yoktu.
Bir yandan cool kız imajımı korumaya
çalışıyorum, bir yandan da Lauren’a
alttan alttan ya yapmasak mı?
ne gerek var işte!
Eve dönelim.
Ne güzel bir gün geçirdik diyorum Loren’da
kızım saçmalama o kadar geldim buraya,
yapmak zorundasın diyor.
İçimde sanki iki tane Ecem tartışıyor.
Biri el kol hareketleriyle.
İsyan ve korku içinde
ne yapıyoruz? diyor.
Diğeri de, ya ölür müyüz yapsak diyor.
Arkadaş grubuna da mahcup olmamak
için 10 saniyeliğine
gözümü karartıyorum ve tamam diyorum.
Endişe eden Ecem’e de ya yapacağız artık
evet dedik yapacak bir şey yok diyorum.
Lauren oradan bana dönüp
″What’re you doing?″ diye bakıyor.
Binmeden boyunuzu ölçüyorlar.
En az 1.37 olmanız lazım.
Diyorum belki ben oradan yırtarım.
Öyle böyle emile çömüle
boyumu ölçüyorum o da olmuyor.
Lauren zaten at gibi bir kız.
Yani ben ne oldu anlamadan 5 dakika içinde
kendimi Kingda Ka’ın o en cazip
ön koltuklarında otururken buluyorum.
Arkadan bir kız kemerleri tek
tek kitlemeye başlıyor.
Çıkırt, çıkırt, çıkırt bana
o an dank ediyor.
Ben ne yapıyorum?
O an tam yerimden kalkacağım
kız ″çıkırt″ diye beni de kitliyor.
O sesle ben o korumaya
çalıştığım cool kız imajı var ya tamamen
vücudumu terk ediyor, diyorum
yarın da dönüyorum.
Başlarım bu işe ve bütün can havliyle
bağırmaya başlıyorum.
″Çıkarın
beni buradan istemiyorum!″
″Kaldırın beni buradan″.
Bayağı olay çıkardım.
Arkamı döndüm.
Bütün tren bana bakıyor.
Arkadaşlarım kikir kikir gülüyorlar.
Kimse beni kale almıyor.
″Too late!″ çok geç diyorlar.
Megafonda 10′dan
geriye sayım başladı.
Ben tir tir titriyorum.
3... 2... 1.
ve asla tahmin edemeyeceğim
bir hızla.
Hani o çizgi filmlerde vardır ya,
yüzünüzün kafatasınızı bıraktığı görseli
aynen o şekilde beş saniyede
en üst noktaya çıktık.
O an benim için zaman durmuş gibiydi.
Sanki dünya ayaklarımın altındaydı ve
içimden bu manzaradan büyülendiğimi
çok hatırlıyorum.
Düşüşümüz 3 saniye sürdü ve biz bitiş
noktasına vardığımızda ben kahkahalarla
ay bir daha yapmak istiyorum, nolur
bir daha yapalım diyordum.
E noldu?
Tam 10 saniye önce beni
o zorla kitledikleri
koltuktan şimdi
kalkmak istemiyordum.
Zaten önümde hiç sıra olmadığı için aynı
koltuklarda kalmamıza izin verdiler ve
biz günümüzü iki
Kingda Ka ile sonlandırdık.
Benim galiba hayatta bir şeyi yapmaktan
korktuğum en son an buydu.
Korkunun öbür tarafına geçtiğimde
hayat bambaşkaydı.
Özgürlüktü, maceraydı.
Yaşadığım değil, hayatta olduğum hissiydi
korktuğum şeyin üzerine gidip onu
tattığım zaman hayatın asıl orada
olup bittiğini fark ettim.
Hayat oradaydı.
Çünkü niye biliyor musunuz?
Korkunun altında aslında arzu yatıyordu.
Korkunun öbür yüzü arzuydu.
Cesur olma arzusu.
Hayat hakkını vererek yaşama arzusu.
Peki biz neden böyle yaşamıyoruz?
Neden bir anlam ifade etmeyen,
bizi mutlu etmeyen,
bizi monotonluğun içine sürükleyen,
hiç ölme telaşımız da olmadan sanki
sonsuza kadar yaşayacakmışız
gibi hayatlarımızı geçiriyoruz?
Neden benliğimize ters düşen
sahte hayatlar yaşıyoruz?
Bizi ne durduruyor?
Alman filozof Martin Heidegger, ″Varlık ve
Zaman″ adlı eserinde insanların kendi
tercihleri olmadan ve bir kullanım
kılavuzu da olmadan bu dünyaya
fırlatıldıklarını söyler ve buna
dünyada varolma hali der.
Yani kimse bize doğarken doğmak istiyor
musun ya bir düşün, bize iki gün sonra
geri dön demez.
Önceden başkaları tarafından sınırlarının
çizildiği, kurallarının konduğu bir
dünyaya şutlanıveriyoruz resmen.
Fırlatıldığımız bu dünyada
bize dayatılanlar işte
gelenekler, görenekler, imkanlar,
imkansızlıklar, toplum yapısı içinde bazı
kararlar veriyor, tercihler yapıyor
ve ilgi duyduğumuz dünyada var
olmaya çalışıyoruz.
Aslında hepimiz derinden otantik hayatlar
yaşamak istiyoruz ama bunun önüne
pek çok şey geçebiliyor.
Heidegger,
bu bizim dünya ile olan iletişimizi
tanımlayan iki tane zaman
konseptinden bahseder.
Bunlardan birincisi dünya zamanı.
Hani bu başkalarının organize
olmak için uydurduğu,
bizi işte bu robotik monoton
hayata sürükleyen zaman.
Bu zamanda dar görüşlü, kör inançlı,
dedikoducu, başkalarının hayatlarını çok
ilgi duyan ve kendi hayatlarını
sorgulamayan insanlar yaşar.
Bu insanlar saatlerce başkalarının
hayatları, evlilikleri, cinsel tercihleri,
sosyal medyadaki stilleri, ebeveynlik
hayatları böyle başka işleri yokmuş gibi
saatlerce telefonlarında
kaydırırlar aşağı doğru.
Heidegger ikinci olarak orjinal
zamandan bahseder.
Bu kavramda insan zamansal bir coşkudur.
Zamanın ta kendisidir.
Dünyada olduğunu hisset diye var olduğunu
farkında olan ve kendi hayatına
ilgi gösterip hayatını sorgulayan
insanlardır.
Ve Heidegger der ki, biz eğer orjinal
zamanda yaşayabiliyorsak ancak bu zaman
başkaların hayatlarını dikkate almadan
otantik bir hayat yaşayabiliriz.
Düşünebiliyor musunuz Heidegger bunu
1927′de söylemiş sosyal medyadan
bir asır önce neredeyse.
Şu an ki durum çok çok daha vahim.
Heidegger bu kötü durumu tersine
çevirmek için bir öğüt verir.
Dünya zamanını bu bahsettiğim birinci
zamanı kapatmak, onu sessize almak yani
Pazartesi sendromu Salı sallanır.
″Throw Back Thursday″ bir tbt atayım.
Cuma cumartesi geldi gece çıkmamız lazım.
Pazar brunch’ı sosyal medyada son trend
var hemen ona göre post yapmalıyım
geç kalmadan gibi.
Böyle başkalarının dikte ettiği
zamandan kurtulmak.
Orjinal zamanda yaşayabilmemiz
için Heidegger bize
kendi çevremize odaklanmamızı söyler.
Yani gerçekten tanıdığımız
insanlara, gerçekten içinde
yaşadığımız çevreye.
Instagram bizde takip ettiğimiz insanların
sanki kendi çevremize ait oldukları
ilüzyonunu yaratır.
Komşu kızının dedikodusunu yapıyor gibi
kendimizde Angelina Jolie dedikodusu yapma
rahatlığı hissederiz.
Ah o Brad’den çekmediği kalmadı
nur yüzlümün.
Selena Gomez ile Hailey
Bieber barışmış mı?
Allahım bu hayatımın en güzel günü.
Emin misin hayatının en
güzel günü olduğuna?
Başkalarının hayatlarının üzerinden
yaşıyorsanız bu kendi hayatınızı teğet
geçiyorsunuz demektir.
Siz eğer sosyal medya takip ettiğiniz
insanlarla bir gün gerçekten tanışmak,
onlarla arkadaş olmak, onlarla aynı
mesleği yapmayı düşünmüyorsanız, onlardan
ilham almak yerine onlar yüzünden kendi
hayatınızdan nefret ediyor ve
“biz bu dünyaya izlemeye gelmişiz ya.”
Veya “ay hayatı onun kadar sevmek
istiyorum” diyorsanız burada çok büyük
bir tehlike var.
Zaten toplumumuzda insanların haklarına,
düşüncelerine, özgürlüklerine karşı kafa
yapısı çok kötü.
Kadın hakları, LGBTQ hakları,
doğa hakları, insan hakları,
hayvan hakları, kimin
hakkı varsa ezilmekte.
Sosyal medya bu durumu çok daha
kötü bir yere sürüklüyor.
Annem ablamla bana büyürken
büyük bir ders aşılamıştır.
Başkaları bizi ilgilendirmez.
Ama anne Ayşe de o partiye gidiyor.
Bizi fark etmez.
Ama annem bütün okul o
ayakkabılardan giyiyor.
Bizi ilgilendirmez.
Bence
ben o yüzden hep kendi yolumda yürüdüm.
Kimse ile kendimi karşılaştırmadım.
Biri bir şeyi benden önce başardıysa
panik olmadım.
O kendi zaman çizelgesinde gidiyor, ben
kendi zaman çizelgemde diye düşündüm.
Ben ortaokuldayken annem Japonya'ya gitti.
Döndüğünde merakla ona en çok
aklında kalan şey neydi?
diye sordum.
Ben bekliyorum ki işte.
Sushiler, tempuralar, Geishalar, ne
bileyim alttan ısıtmalı tuvaletler falan.
Japonların bir atasözü dedi.
Kendinle o kadar çok ilgilen ki
başkalarıyla ilgilenmeye vaktin kalmasın.
Düşünsenize başkalarının hayatlarından
ilgiyi ve zamanı kendimize yatırdığımızı
Süpermen olmuştuk ya sadece sen
ben bireysel olarak değil toplum
olarak çok iyi bir yerdeydik.
Çünkü sen kendi hayatına bakarsan
başkaları da senin onu yadırgayacağın
korkusu olmadan yaşayabilir
kendi hayatını.
Hepimiz çok daha mutlu oluruz.
Bence bizim yeniden hatırlamamız gereken
şey, bir gün öleceğimizi gerçeği.
Sonsuza kadar yaşayacakmışız gibi
geçiriyoruz günlerimizi.
Sanki her geçen gün yeni bir doğuş, yeni
bir varoluş, yeni bir şans değil de
yine başlayıp yine biten bir şey.
Monoton hayatın bir parçası,
hiçbir şeyden farkı olmayan
bir şey gibi bakıyoruz.
Bence bizim hayatımıza aciliyet duygusunu
geri kazandırmamız lazım.
Günlerim sayılı.
Acil mutlu olmam lazım.
Emekliliğe ayrılınca değil.
O kiloyu verince değil.
Ay bi şunu atlatalım da bakarız değil.
O tatile çıkınca değil,
maaşım yatınca değil.
Çok daha acil.
Şimdi de var olmamız ve o bütün gün
elimizde gezdiğimiz kıskançlık,
dikdörtgenlerinin mürekkep karası
içinden çıkmamız lazım.
Peki nasıl yapacağız?
Nasıl başkalarının bizim hayatımız için
yaptığı bu algılar, yargılar, ön kesmeler,
ayak kaydırmalar, ocak söndürmeler
ülkenin hali içinden nasıl sıyrılıp
hayatın kapısını çalacağız?
Nasıl başkalarının bizim için yazdığı
o kullanım kılavuzlarını bir bir
yakıp atacağız?
Bunun tek bir cevabı var ″Aksiyon″.
Korkmadan, ne pahasına olursa olsun,
kendini bulma pahasına, mutlu olma
pahasına aksiyona geçmek, dünyada
gerçekten var olduğunu fark etmek,
orjinal zamanda yaşamak ve aciliyet
duygusuyla bir gün öleceğimiz gerçeğini
düşünerek acil harekete geçmemiz lazım.
Hiç sahip olmadığım bir şeye sahip olmak
için hiç yapmadığın bir şey yapman gerek.
Sen eğer mevcut sınırlarının dışına
çıkmaz, monoton hayatın içinde hayal
kurmaya devam edersen hayallerin
hayal olarak kalır.
Mesele aslında başarmak da değil.
Mesele, başarmak için olman gereken insana
dönüşmekte yavaş yavaş.
İşin gerçeği de sizin için
bunu sizden başka kimse yapamaz.
Sizin için en iyisini ne toplum, ne en
iyi arkadaşınız, ne aileniz bilir.
Sizin için en iyisini siz bilirsiniz.
Tutku, içimizde oluşan bir kıvılcım,
bir kalp çarpıntısı.
Elinizi kalbinize koyduğunuzda onu
mutlu eden şeyin ne olduğunu siz
zaten çok iyi biliyorsunuz.
Bilmiyorsanız da acilen yeni şeyler
denemenizi ve durmamanızı diliyorum,
o tutkuyu bulana kadar.
Hepimiz aslında eşsiz yolları
olan eşsiz varlıklarız.
Eğer siz böyle hissetmiyorsanız bu
belki sizin de suçunuz değil.
Bu toplumun suçu.
Bir çiçek açmıyorsa siz çiçeği mi
suçlarsınız içinde bulunduğu toprağı mı?
etrafındaki hava koşullarını mı?
ona verilen suyu mu?
Madem isteğimiz dışında geliyoruz bu
dünyaya, bari isteğimiz içinde yaşayalım.
Senin, benim nasıl yaşamamız gerektiğini
düşündüğün gibi değil.
Sen kendi işine bak.
Sen kendin o kadar çok ilgilen
ki bana vaktin kalmasın.
Doğmayı seçmemiş olabiliriz ama yeniden
doğmak hepimizin seçimi.
Her canlı bir gün ölümü tadacaktır.
Kim geçmedi Zincirlikuyu Mezarlığı’nın bu
büyük kapılarından
ve düşünmedi üstüme iyilik sağlık,
nereden çıktı bu şimdi diye.
Bence bu harika bir hatırlatma.
Hepimizin bir gün öleceği gerçeği ile
acilen barışması ve aciliyet duygusuyla
harekete geçmesi lazım.
Ve biliyorum, harekete geçmek çok zor.
Geçmemek için milyon tane sebep var işte
bu noktada eğer sen sevdiğin işi yaparsan,
bir gün bu bana ekmek kapısı olur mu diye
düşünmeden, işte o zaman her gün kendini
böyle motive edip, gaza getirip başka
yerde mutluluğu aramana da gerek kalmaz.
Ben.
Mesela.
Bütün hayatım boyunca elimde bir kameram
insanları çektim, montajladım
her arkadaş grubu gördüğümde onlara
dans senkronizasyonları, ağız
senkronizasyonu yaptırdım.
Gerçek bir kariyere dönüşmeden önce
benim için yönetmenlik,
sadece ben sevdiğim için farkında olmadan
yaptığım bir şeydi ve okuduğum bir şeydi.
Hiçbir zaman ben film okuyorum
ama filmci olacağım.
Mezuniyete ne yapacağım? para
kazanabilecek miyim? diye düşünmedim.
Onu doktor annem düşündü.
Onun için yandan da bir psikoloji okudum.
Ama ben sadece sevdiğim şeye enerjimi
verdim ve o meslek beni buldu.
Unutmayın arkadaş evren hareketi sever.
Evrene size yardım edecek
materyalleri verin.
Hayal edip durmayın, aksiyona geçin.
Şimdi.
Yapmak istediğiniz bir şey hakkında
düşünmek, tereddüt etmek, iş yapmaktan
korkmak, beyaz tahtalara yazmak, listeler
yapmak yerine onu yapmanın, onun üzerine
atlamanın zamanı.
Ve asla hazır hissetmeyi de beklemeyin.
Hiçbir zaman hazır hissetmeyeceksiniz.
Ben 34 milyon izlenen YouTube trendlerde
bir numara olan ilk klibimi çekmeden
bir gece önce hala Youtube’dan klip
nasıl yönetilir diye bakıyordum.
Yönetirken öğrendim, çekerken öğrendim.
Şimdi hareket zamanı.
Ne gerek var diyenlere çok gerek var ya
bence hiç yapma sen o işi diyenlere sen
yapma, ay hiç kalkışma
diyenlere kalkıştım bile
″bye″ deme zamanı.
O seni korkutan şey her ne ise.
Toplum mu?
Ailen mi?
Sen mi?
Benim yaptığım gibi 10 saniye gözünü
karart ve o roller coaster’a bin.
Etrafında doğru insanlar olduğunda bu
zaten senin hayatında yaptığın
en eğlenceli ve
en anlamlı yolculuk olacak.
O zaman ″çıkırt″.
3...
2...
1.
Teşekkürler.